22 octobre 1984 jean marie et christine
villemin enterrent leur fils grégory 4
ans retrouvé mort dans la vologne
quelques jours plus tôt un prénom qui
sera synonyme d'une des plus grandes
énigmes criminelles françaises mais
aussi synonyme de dérive médiatique
le média télévision je pense les limites
accordée à la presse la déontologie le
respect de la présomption d'innocence
très vite tout ça est bafouée un
journaliste doit être neutre de quoi
n'ont pu travailler sur son est une
collection je sais pas je suis pas du
métier m'enfin moi il me semble que
c'est comme ça que ça se fait les
journalistes sont à l'affût il traque
les gendarmes font pression sur les
témoins créer des scénarios porte des
accusations
un emballement qui est permis voire
encouragée par le juge d'instruction
jean michel lambert mais aussi par les
gendarmes on en est exactement au même
point qu'à midi et que eric ya deux
jours malheureusement et si jamais vous
pouvez nous aider
ce sera bien accueilli les avocats
participent aussi à cette surenchère
sans limite en alimentant les rumeurs
objectif disculper leur client en
accusant l'adversaire rumeurs qui auront
une fin tragique
la rumeur a poussé jean marie ou si j'en
arrive ils m'ont battue et le ministre
de la justice de l'époque tente alors un
appel au calme pour l impression que les
confrontations ont lieu maintenant dans
les salles de rédaction avec un micro
toujours tendue je repars je crois
encore une fois que la justice ait
besoin de pluie de cartons
les journalistes eux mêmes sont
conscients de ces débordements les
journalistes nous y compris hélas ont
piétiné les traces passé les témoins à
la question et tirer des conclusions
avant même les enquêteurs
les lecteurs auditeurs téléspectateurs
sont avides de connaître la suite
alors les tirages augmente et la course
nouvelles les plus obscènes prime sur le
devoir d'information comme le dénoncer
ce journaliste du canard enchaîné
je ne vois plus la formation là on est
dans un système marchand ou la photo la
plus horrible où la plus émouvante et
encore l'émotion ça se fabrique aussi ça
nous manque ça vaut de l'argent on en
voit plus de trente ans plus tard le
mystère plane toujours
et certains journalistes se sont
repentis comme laurence lacour qui a
dénoncé toutes ces dérives dans un livre
vous avez arrêté le métier vous avez
jeté votre carte de presse
c'est des choses lourdes
moi j'ai démissionné
vous êtes rendu compte assez vite que
c'était plus beaux sinon c'était plus
facile et bien moi je dis toujours je
suis une accidentés du travail
par cet appel par cette affaire
[Musique]